bonjour à tous La séance est
ouverte l'ordre du jour appelle les
question au
gouvernement la première va être posée
par le président Pancher pour le groupe
lot madame la premierère ministre mon
engagement politique comme tous les
parlementaires de mon groupe a toujours
été guidé par la recherche de mesures
efficaces et justes efficace car nos
concitoyens sont de plus en plus
désabusés de la politique et croient de
moins en moins parole publique juste
parce que les valeurs de la République
sont primordiales à nos yeux notamment
l'idéal de
fraternité il y a quelques semaines vous
étiez engagé à présenter un texte sur le
traitement de l'immigration irrégulière
attendu par de nombreux Français et de
françaises le groupe lot a depuis le
début rappelé l'importance de présenter
un texte équilibré sans angélisme ni
extrémisme c'est à cela que nous avons
uvré en commission avec la
régularisation des métiers en tension le
maintien de l'aide méd d'Ét
l'interdiction du placement en lieu de
rétention administrative de tous les
mineurs l'intégration par la langue
aujourd'hui le texte s'éloigne dans
l'esprit et dans sa rédaction avec son
objectif
principal nous souhaaitions comme les
Français un vrai débat nous en sommes
privés les Français sont médusés face à
des intrigues des entourloupette d'un
autre temps dans une commission mixte
paritaire
opaque quel spectacle donnons-nous c'est
un échec collectif et notre démocratie
est malade nous avons besoin de plus de
transparence de débat de concertation en
amont de recherche de consensus c'est la
grandeur de notre pays patrie des droits
de l'homme qui en
dépend raisissons-nous collectivement
avant que les extrémistes prennent le
pouvoir dans notre pays madame la
Première ministre la loi qui va sortir
de la CMP sera-t-elle plus efficace en
quoi ce texte sera-t-il plus juste
par-delà de cette loi madame la Premier
ministre quand quand il y aura-t-il dans
notre pays un chèque démocratique qu'on
écoute les Français avec des référendums
qu'on respecte le Parlement en le
laissant s'exprimer et délibérer enfin
sereinement merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président la parole est à madame la
Première
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les député
monsieur le président Bertrand
Pancher vous le savez et c'est une
préoccupation que vous et votre groupe
partagez nous devons éloigner plus
rapidement ceux qui n'ont pas le droit
de se maintenir sur notre sol et mieux
intégrer ceux que nous choisissons
d'accueillir c'est une attente forte de
nos concitoyens c'est nécessaire pour
notre pays depuis des mois avec les
ministres Gérald armanin et Olivier
dusopte un travail intense est mené pour
bâtir un texte qui apporte des réponses
efficaces aux attentes des Français dans
le respect des valeurs
républicaines ces échanges vous vous y
avez été largement associés ainsi que
votre groupe la semaine dernière encore
nous vous avons rencontré le ministre de
l'Intérieur le ministre des Relations
avec le Parlement et moi-même avec votre
co-président Christophe
neéelen monsieur le président Bertrand
Pancher vous me posez deux questions
claires en quoi ce texte sera-t-il plus
efficace en quoi ce texte sera-t-il plus
juste je vous réponds clairement ce
projet de loi rendra notre système plus
efficace parce qu'il va simplifier
drastiquement nos procédures et réduire
les délais de traitement des demandes
d'asile parce qu'il va permettre
d'expulser plus rapidement les étrangers
délinquants ou radicalisés parce qu'il
donneent des moyens accrus pour lutter
contre l'immigration illégale parce
qu'il porte des mesures spécifiques
adapté à chaque territoire pour les
outrmes mais ça n'est pas mais ça n'est
pas tout monsieur le Président Pancher
ce projet de loi rendra notre système
plus juste parce qu'il interdit le
placement des mineurs en rétention
administrative parce qu'il renforce les
sanctions contre les passeurs parce
qu'il fait pleinement du travail un
levier d'intégration notamment dans les
filières en tension monsieur le
Président Pancher avec la majorité avec
tous les députés constructifs avec votre
groupe nous voulons un texte solide un
texte efficace un texte juste c'est
notre cap et nous nous y tenons je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Bruno
milen pour le groupe
démocrate merci merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires monsieur le ministre
mercredi dernier s terminé la COP 28 et
le groupe démocrate qui depuis toujours
plaide pour une écologie réaliste
pragmatique et efficace se joint à moi
pour vous féliciter quant à l'accord
historique que vous avez négocié au nom
de la France n'en déplaise à nos
oppositions c'est bien un accord
historique qui a été trouvé pour la
première fois l'accord pousse les pays à
abandonneré les combustibles fossiles il
envoie un message fort aux investisseurs
à l'ensemble des décideurs politiques
mais aussi et surtout à la population il
est parfaitement en phase avec la
politique énergétique engagée par notre
majorité depuis 6 ans et prouve que nous
allons dans le bon sens dans le sens de
l'histoire lever ce tabou n'avait rien
d'évident à l'ouverture de cette COP et
était un préalable important pour
avancer vers la neutralité carbone la
diplomatie dont les pays les plus
développés ont fait preuve a permis de
passer d'un accord trop peu ambitieux à
un accord à la hauteur des enjeux
rappelons-le au Cassandre de cet
hémicycle la France est l'un des pays
les moins émetteurs de gaz à effet de
serre et l'un de ceux qui baisse le plus
drastiquement ses émissions au prer
semestre 2023 la France a baissé ses
émissions de 4,3 %. cette baisse est
notamment portée par le bâtimentaire
avec une baisse de 7 % preuve que les
politiques publiques de rénovation
thermique des bâtiments fonctionnent en
comparaison avec le quinquena de
François Hollande nous avons doublé nos
baisses annuelles avec une diminution de
55 millions de tonnes entre 2017 et 2022
quand entre 2012 et 2017 malgré la
présence des écologistes gouvernement et
dans la majorité elle ne fut que de 24
millions de tonnes ainsi Monsieur le
Ministre chaque pays devra présenter de
nouveaux engagements en 2025 en fonction
des orientations données à Dubaï
pourriez-vous je vous prie nous
détailler pour la France les grandes
lignes de ce que seront ses engagements
je vous
remercie merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des
territoires madame madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député
milienne le dérèglement climatique
s'accélère ses effets sont de plus en
plus visibles et nous le constatons
partout sur la planète entre les
mégafeux du Canada les inondations un
certain nombre d'endroits et face à cela
cette cop de Dubaï elle était annoncée
comme étant une forme de Cop de la
dernière chance avec tous les signaux
qu'elle n'était pas placée sous les
meilleurs hospices un président qui
était à la tête d'une compagnie
pétrolière et un état lui-même dépendant
des énergies fossiles elle a pourtant
débouché sur un accord historique pour
au moins trois raisons historique parce
que pour la première fois
196 pays dans le monde se sont mis
d'accord pour indiquer que la transition
devait se faire hors des énergie fossile
historique parce que pour la première
fois une COP avec 196 pays a consacré la
place du
nucléaire historique parce que pour la
première fois l'engagement de tripl
capacité des énergies renouvelables a
été prise par 196 pays tous ces éléments
soulignent la nécessité d'une diplomatie
environnementale puissante ça n'est pas
parce qu'on discute qu'avec des gens
avec lesquels on est d'accord qu'on
réussi à obtenir des résultats et malgré
les critique et les crit d'orfais la
vérité c'est qu'avant l'accord de Paris
la trajectoire de réchauffement mondial
était de 4 degrés et même si nous devons
continuer à accélérer les efforts ces
moments sont des moments qui permettent
à chacun d'être face à la fois la
science et à la réalité de ce qui nous
attend pour prendre des engagements
alors face à ça il n'y a finalement que
deux catégories de gens qui sont
profondément déçus les climatopulistes
qui nous expliquent qu'il n'y a pas de
dérèglement climatique ou qu'il est
exagéré et je pense évidemment à
l'extrême droite de cette assemblée
quand je le dis et les climat défétistes
qui sont à l'extrême gauche et qui
aimeraient conserver le monopole de la
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique
et nous faire croire alors qu'il n'avait
pas de résultat quand ils étaient en
responsabilité que ce serait à qui
confinerait à faire confiance merci
beaucoup monsieur le
[Applaudissements]
ministre la parole est à Madame Sylvie
Bonet pour le groupet
républicain madame la Présidente chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre de l'économie le
groupe Casino est une entreprise
d'envergure internationale qui a des
racines profondément ancrées dans la
Loire que je représente ici ce groupe a
été placé fin octobre en procédure de
sauvegarde accélérée afin de mettre en
œuvre la restructuration de sa dette
même si un accord semble se profiler
avec Intermarché et au champ pour le
rachat de 313 hypermarchés et
supermarchés les 55000 salariés employés
en France sont aujourd'hui extrêmement
inquiets et en particulier les 22000
salariés des anciennes casinos face à
une telle incertitude quant à l'avenir
du groupe de ces milliers de magasins
sur l'ensemble du territoire national de
ces entrepôts de ses emplois je souhaite
non seulement exprimer mon profond
attachement à l'entreprise et à ses
salariés mais j'en appelle aussi et
surtout à la responsabilité du
gouvernement ce sont des milliers
d'emplois directs et des dizaines de
milliers d'emplois indirects qui sont
menacés 3000 personnes au total dans les
sièges sociaux de Saint-Étienne et
vitere sur scène 3000 personnes dans les
entrepôts 16000 personnes dans les
supermarchés hypermarchés l'enjeu est
considérable c'est pourquoi dimanche
dernier nous de nombreux élus au côté
des salariés qui craignent de perdre
leur emploi pouvez-vous nous dire
monsieur le ministre combien d'emplois
seront sauvés au siège de Saint-Étienne
certains magasins ne risquent-ils pas de
fermer ou d'être confrontés à des
problèmes de concurrence pouvez-vous
rassurer les milliers de salariés et
leurs familles à quelques jours de Noël
vous engagez-vous à ce que tous les
employés soient
sauvés je vous
remerci la parole est à Monsieur Roland
lescur ministre en charge de
l'Industrie merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les Députés madame la
députée Syvie Brunet merci pour votre
question je voudrais aussi saluer le
député Quentin batillon député de
Saint-Étienne qui suit ce dossier de
très
près c'est
notamment c'est notamment à sa demande
que Bruno Le Maire que j'excuse
aujourd'hui a reçu l'intersyndicale il y
a une dizaine de jours vous le savez du
fait d'erreur stratégiqu importantes le
groupe Casino a été durablement affaibli
ces derniers trimestres et grâce à
l'action notamment du gouvernement cet
été nous avons trouvé un repreneur
Daniel krzinski au au prix de passif
social et fiscal de la part de l'État
qui s'est engagé à reprendre
l'intégralité du groupe depuis des
pertes énormes 500 millions d'euros en 3
mois ont conduit le repreneur à revoir
la situation et à mettre en vente avec
l'accord du propriétaire actuel
l'ensemble des hypermarchés des
supermarchés de la marque et les
anthoposogistiques deux offres se sont
présentées vendredi et vous le savez le
repreneur a choisi l'offre la mieux
disante à la fois d'un point de vue
social d'un point de vue économique et
d'un point de vue de la logistique
puisque 5 des 13 entrepôts seront sauvés
cette reprise qui a été acceptée par le
repreneur va nous permettre à la fois et
c'est un un engagement ferme sur lequel
l'État sera sans concession le maintien
du siège social de casino à
Saint-Étienne 2 la préservation d'une
gestion opérationnelle réussie des deux
opérations de transaction la reprise par
auchamp et Intermarché de l'ensemble
l'ensemble des hypermarchés des
supermarchés d'une bonne partie des
entrepôts et la préservation autant que
possible de l'emploi à la fois à
Saint-Étienne et dans l'ensemble du
territoire l'État sera extrêmement
vigilant à la qualité de l'exécution de
cette stratégie au maintien de l'emploi
au siège à Saint-Étienne à la capacité
collective que nous aurons à donner des
perspectives durables au groupe Casino
l'état Bruno Le Maire en premier suivra
cette situation de très près je m'y
engage devant vous madame la député mon
ministre madame la
députée bon il est il est regrettable
que Monsieur le Maire ne soit pas là
madame la Première ministre j'ai un
courrier à remettre à monsieur le
Président de la République de la part de
l'intersyndicale et des parlementaires
de la Loire merci merci
beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur Andy
carbra pour le groupe la France
insoumise merci madame la Présidente ma
question ne s'adresse pas à Monsieur
Gérald haranin le ministre légitime de
l'intérieur mais à Madame ellisabeth
borne chef du gouvernement où est passé
le barrage républicain où est passé le
barrage du candidat Macron réélu en 2022
qui disait aux Français que son élection
était leur réponse à l'extrême droite où
est passé le barrage du candidat Macron
en 2017 qui affirmait l'immigration ne
devrait pas inquiéter la population
française elle se révèle une chance d'un
point de vue économique culturel et
social où est passé le barrage du
ministre Macron qui en 2015 pensait de
l'immigration quelle est la dignité de
l'ensemble de nos pays notamment de la
France d'être à la hauteur événements
estaccueillir dignement où est passé le
barrage quand le parti du président de
la République s'apprête à voter une loi
écrite par Le Pen copié parti mettre en
cause le droit du sol instaurer la
déchéance de nationalité s'attaquer aux
familles instaurer une préférence
nationale pour les aides sociales
conditionner les études des étrangers
dans notre pays ce sont toutes des
mesures de Jean-Marie Le Pen vous avez
cédé surt mais surtout vous avez cédé
par aveuglement par orgueil par
faiblesse vous passez par de subord les
principes les plus élément de notre
République collègu de
majorité tout nous oppose mais nous
savons qui est le véritable ennemi c'est
la peste brune c'est la gangraine
mortifère de la xénophobie ce sont les
agents de la haine qui trouvent un bou
émissaire dans l'étranger et qui salue
aujourd'hui ce projet de loi la
meilleure défense contre l'extrême
droite c'est de la combattre en faisant
tout le contraire de ce qu'elle veut
accueillir accueillir dignement nous
partis dans l'Union Populaire nous
tiendrons bon contre votre projet de loi
contre le chantage du Sénat contre l'é
de Le Pen vous les libéraux où
serez-vous avec l'Arque républicain ou
dans l'Arque
réactionnaire je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur Gérald
armanin ministre de l'Intérieur et des
[Applaudissements]
outresm mer
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député de la France
insoumise où était votre bonne morale
lorsque vous avez draguer les voies du
rassemblement national pour la motion de
Roget où étai vos valeurs de gauche
quand vous aveztisé avec Madame Le Pen
pour ne pas faire votre travail de
député d'étudier pendant 15 jour le
débat alors aujourd'hui vous faites
semblant de découvrir la
Constitution vous faites semblant de
voir que vous avez rejeté dans les bras
directement du Sénat le texte que vous
n'avez pas voulu
étudier et
désormais par des morales et de la vertu
vous vous baladez en regrettant les
conséquences des causes que vous avez
créé alors monsieur le
député pas croire que vous êtes dans
l'arc républicain quand vous draguez les
voix du Front national vous nous ferez
pas croire que vous êtes moral lorsque
c'est cette majorité qui va interdire le
placement des mineurs dans les centres
de
rétention vous ne ferez pas croire que
vous êtes du côté de la moral quand
cette majorité qui fera avec les
républicains une mesure de
régularisation pour les travailleurs
sans papier et vous nous ferez pas
croire que vous êtes du côté de la
gauche morale lorsque vous êtes de
sourire à Madame Le Pen et que vous vous
levez ensemble pour applaudir devant la
mort de la démocratie
parlementaire je vous remercie monsieur
le
ministre monsieur le député aujourd'hui
nous voterons pas le 22e texte sur
l'immigration mais sur ce qui nous dit
fini quelle valeur donnons-nous à une
vie la vie d'un enfant mort en
Méditerranée la valeur de cette vie
c'est notre propre valeur c'est ce qui
définit notre civilisation ce qui
définit notre République et c'est ce qui
définit notre humanité je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre monsieur le député vous avez
joué le tritin vous avez choisi la
politique du pire et désormais vous
faites pleurer des larmes de crocodil
mais c'est larme monsieur le député
c'est celle que vous avez pactisé avec
le rassemblement national et ça vous
mettraz longtemps à vous en
remettre merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
allez s'il vous plaît on écoute
l'orateur suivant monsieur Anthony Bro
pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à Madame agè
pagierunach ministre de la transition
énergétique madame la ministre adopté il
y a 8 ans déjà les accords de Paris ont
permis d'endiguer la hausse inexorable
de nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre
tandis que sans eux une hausse de 16 %
de nos émissions auraiit été constaté en
2030 elle ne serait finalement que de 3
% grâce à la COP 2021 c'est une première
victoire cert mais qui reste à nuancer
ces 3 % de hausse sont en effet très
éloigné de la baisse de 43 % préconisé
par le GC il convient toutefois de noter
qu'un signal a été envoyé qu'une prise
de conscience en est suivie et que des
efforts sont déployés pour réussir cette
indispensable transition dans la suite
direct et très attendu les négociations
pres qui ont eu cours aux Émirats Arab
Unis du 30 novembre au 13 décembre se
sont conclu par un accord historique
loin d'être acrit à quelques heures
encore de la fin de la conférence
celui-ci a finalement permis d'aboutir
un texte important qui dénonce de
manière inédite la responsabilité des
énergies fossiles responsable de 80 %
des émissions de gaz et effet de serre
dans le réchauffement climatique que
nous vivons cet accord signé par les 197
parties il y a quelques jours et
d'autant plus significatif que les
négociations se sont déroulées dans le
golfe Persique là où même les plus
grands pays exportateurs de pétrole se
situent là où même les décisions de
l'OPEP sont en partie pris et concerté
nous pouvons donc saluer ce grand pas en
avant sur la confiance entre les pays de
l'hémisphère Nord et de l'hémisphère sud
sur l'ambition portée par cette
conférence et sur la solidarité dans les
financements pour y parvenir ainsi
madame la ministre au regard des besoins
de financement de cette transition qui
nécessiterait entre 2000 et 2600
pvezv nous indiquer les engagements que
prendra la France danses invessements
majeurs et essentiel pour l'avenir de
notre planète je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame
agè ministre de la transition
énergétique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Bros vous avez raison l'accord de Paris
l'accord de la C 28 de Dubaï est
historique historique d'abord parce
qu'il affirme pour la première fois
depuis 30 ans la sortie des énergies
fossiles de toutes les énergies fossiles
dans un pays pétrolier et parce que la
France et ses alliés occidentaux et ses
alliés pays en développement n'ont rien
lâché jusqu'au bout de la
négociation historique car il réaffirme
la place du nucléaire pour la première
fois dans une COP historique car il
redit l'importance du renouvelable et de
l'efficacité énergétique mais historique
aussi
car il crée la confiance avec les pays
du Sud dans la suite de toute l'action
du Président de la République du sommet
de Paris du pacte de Paris pour les
peuples et la planète qui ont permis de
retisser ce fil de la confiance et de
créer des accords autour du fond pertes
et dommages jusqu'à 700 millions de
dollars pour les pays les plus
vulnérable 100 milliards de dollars
apportés chaque année en 22 en 2023 3
pour les pays en développement et toute
l'action que nous menons pour obtenir
des financements innovants est passer
des milliards au milliards de milliards
pour enfin accélérer la transition
énergétique alors face au rassemblement
national qui et oui qui remet en
question les les analyses du GC mais qui
se précipite dans le Pas de calé quand
il y a des inondations ou face à
l'inaction climatique de la nups qui ne
vote pas l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables nous nous agissons en
solidarité avec les pays du Sud et en
baissant nos émissions de gaz et effet
de serre puisqueaujourd'hui sur les TR
premiers trimestres de l'année nous les
avons baissé de 4,6 % je vous remercie
madame la
ministre alors vraiment s'il vous plaît
faudrait que le niveau sonore baisse un
peu parce que on va pas tenir pendant
toute la séance de QAG donc vraiment
chacun merci de faire un effort
pour écouter le président chassen pour
le groupe
GDR madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues madame la Première ministre
après le rejet inédit du projet de loi
sur l'immigration vous êtes sur le point
de commettre
l'irréparable depuis plusieurs jours les
pires tractations politiciennes ont lieu
dans le HU clos de Matignon et de
l'Élysée au mépris de la séparation des
pouvoirs vous
instrumentalisez la CMP pour contourner
le Parlement et conclure coûte que coûte
avec la droite l'air alignée sur les
positions du rassemblement
national madame la Première
ministre mesurez bien votre
responsabilité historique l'élection du
président Macron devait nous prémunir
des pires avanis du programme de
l'extrême droite aujourd'hui de bout
vous êtes devenu le
marchepied comment pouvez-vous ainsi
céder sur nos valeurs sur des questions
aussi essentielles que l'aide médicale
d'État le droit du sol le droit aux
prestation social la déchéance de
nationalité mes chers collègues de la
majorité la seule position juste c'est
de tenir bon sur le respect des droits
fondamentaux c'est de refuser toute
disposition discriminatoire mais ch
collègu ne succombez pas au fantasm
véhiculés par l'extrême droite qui se
délecte aujourd'hui de remporter une
victoire idéologique majeure mes chers
collègues je vous le dis solennellement
vous allez écrire ce soir une page de
notre histoire l'histoire d'un pays qui
en ce 19 décembre renoncerit à ses
valeurs
humanistes madame la Première ministre
m chers collègues il est encore temps de
vousaisir n'ajoutez pas le dshonneur à
la compromission ne laissez pas ce texte
de la honte fracturer de manière durable
notre République et René les valeurs
humanist de notre
pays je vous
remercie JECI monsieur
président Mame la première
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le Président
chassigne j'ai beaucoup de respect
monsieur le Président chassigne pour
vous-même et pour votre groupe mais moi
je ne peux pas laisser dire n'importe
quoi sur le contenu de notre texte je ne
peux pas laisser dire n'importe quoi et
en vous écoutant monsieur président
chassigne j'en viens me demander si vous
avez lu le texte dont il est question
alors si alors sortez sortez des slogans
des postures en voulant faire croire en
voulant faire l'amalgame entre notre
texte et les positions de l'extrême
droite les mots les mots ont un sens
monsieur les mots ont un sens monsieur
le Président chassigne l'extrême droite
c'est le rejet des étrangers par
principe parce qu'ils sont étrangers
l'extrême droite c'est la préférence
nationale nous nous croyons à
l'intégration par le travail nous nous
voulons nous nous voulons continuer à
former des talents et à diffuser notre
culture en accueillant des étudiants
internationaux l'extrême
droite l'extrême droite l'extrême droite
c'est le refus d'accueillir même ceux
qui sont en danger le droit d'asile
c'est au cœur de nos valeurs monsieur le
Président chass alors qui
est qui est dans le texte c'est
l'interdiction de placer les mineurs en
rétention administrative c'est une
mesure forte la gauche ne l'a pas fait
ce qui est dans le texte ce qui est dans
le texte c'est la régularisation de
celles et ceux qui travail sans avoir
besoin de l'accord de l'employeur la
gauche ne l'a pas fait ce qui est dans
le texte ce sont des sanctions ferme
contre les passeurs contre les marchands
de sommeil qui profitent des personnes
fragiles la gauche de la pas
fait monsieur le Président chassigne la
nupes est bien mal placé pour faire des
procès en compromission avec l'extrême
droite c'est la nupes qui fait en
permanence des appels du pied au
rassemblement national c'est la nupesse
qui vote avec lui c'est la nupesse avec
sa motion de rejet qui a bloqué le débat
main dans la main avec le rassemblement
national alors soyez clair face à
l'extrême droite face à extrême droite
la nuupesse est dans la collision nous
nous la combattons et avec le ministre
de l'Intérieur et mon gouvernement avec
la majorité nous défendons ce projet de
loi parce qu'il est nécessaire silence
on nentend rien s'il vous
plaît mais nous défendons ce projet de
loi parce qu'il est efficace nous
défendons ce projet de loi parce qu'il
est conforme aux valeurs que j'ai
toujours porté aux valeurs porté par le
président de la République depuis 2017
aux valeurs
[Applaudissements]
républicaines je vous remercie madame la
Première
[Musique]
ministre alors mes chers collègues
vraiment ça va pas être possible de
continuer comme
çaors non non mais alors vous posez vous
posez des questions vous hurlez pendant
les réponses ça n'est pas possible c'est
une séance de question au
gouvernement
[Musique]
alorsc monsieur Gedge monsieur
[Applaudissements]
Gedge allez
[Musique]
allez on redescend la pression s'il vous
plaît monsieur Bild pour le
rassemblement
national merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre personne n'est épargné par la
vie chère femme homme famille salariés
étudiant et retraités en 2023
l'inflation cumulée atteint 20 % tous
les prix s'env en 1 an le simple kilo de
pomme de terre congelé a augmenté de 25
% dans 5 jours nous fêterons Noël fêter
Noël en famille désormais un luxe pour
beaucoup de Français 37 % d'entre eux
redoutent de ne pas pouvoir offrir un
cadeau à leur proches cette année les
associations font face à une explosion
des demandeurs d'aide alimentaire chaque
trimestre 30 % de nouvelles personnes
poussent les portes d' structure d'aide
hier à Vingle j'ai rencontré les
bénévoles de la Banque alimentaire qui
sont débordés mais votre gouvernement
sent tête à marteler que les Français ne
s'approvvrissent pas les chiffres qui
prouvent le contraire sont pourtant
accablants les femmes représentent près
de 60 % des personnes accueillies par le
Secours Catholique ce qui pousse
l'association à parler de féminisation
de la pauvreté dans son dernier rapport
annuel 2 millions de salariés pauvres
n'arrivent plus à vivre dignement de
leur travail près d'un/art des enfants
sont désormais en situation de pauvreté
les retraité souffr autant si bien qu'il
représente désormais 27 % des ménages
pauvres les Français ne vous demandent
pas l'homô mais sohaitent vivre
dignement sans être poussé à la pauvreté
par la vie chère il faut réformer les
règles
de fixation de prix deélectricité il
faut baisser la TVA sur les énergies et
produits de première
nécessité et vous ne faites rien
absolument rien madame la Première
ministre quand allez-vous enfin défendre
les
Français je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame Olivia
grégoard ministre en charge des petites
et moyennes entreprises du commerce de
l'artisanat et du tourisme
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
bilild je me demande en réalité si
consigne a été passé au 88 députés du
rassemblement national de poser chaque
semaine la même question ça vous permet
de cocher des cases tel un bingo parce
que on va vous rappeler des évidences
vous ne voulez pas les entendre mais je
vais les rappeler vous parlez de bacer
la TVA toujours la même rangain alors on
va regarder ensemble en Espagne quel est
le niveau de la TVA alimentaire mesdames
messieurs 9,2 % quel est le niveau de
l'inflation alimentaire ici grâce à
l'action du gouvernement 7,6 % en 8 mois
on a perdu 8 points d'inflation
alimentaire et que se passe-t-il en
Espagne ils ont perdu 2 milliards
d'euros et ils ont 2 % d'inflation
alimentaire en plus alors vos leçons
vous devriez les réviser deè point
baisse de la TVA que vous invoquez elle
est injuste qu'on soit pauvre ou qu'on
soit riche on est concerné de la même
façon la baisse de la TVA elle est
inefficace l'Espagne l'a démontré la
baisse de la TVA je sais que vous n'en
avez cure elle coûte une fortune des
milliards au budget public pour aucun
résultat alors la nouvelle année
arrivant je formule un vœ un peu fou le
V que peut-être un jour vous vous
mettiez à travailler et à prop
vra mesures pour accompagner les
Français parce qu'en attendant cette
majorité cette majorité avec le bouclier
énergie avec le bouclier tarifaire avec
les renégociations commerciales elle a
baissé l'inflation alimentaire de 8
points en 8 mois alors de grâce une bien
belle année et mettez-vous à
travailler je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame
gratiella Melchor pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à Gabriel Atal
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse monsieur le ministre cette
année 2023 a été marqué par de nombreux
phénomènes climatiques exceptionnels des
records de chaleur battu mois après mois
des épisodes canicula plus long et plus
récurrents et des tempêtes toujours plus
dévastatrices comme Karan qui au de
novembre a frappé le Finistère or afin
de mieux appréhender et affronter ces
phénomènes climatiques et leurs
conséquences l'école peut et doit
devenir le premier lieu d'engagement
pour la transition écologique les élèves
les enseignants et les personnels y ont
tout leur rôle ces convictions ce sont
celles que nous partageons ma collègue
Francesca paskini et moi-même dans notre
rapport à travers cinq grands axes
allant du bâti scolaire au contenu
pédagogique en passant par la
restauration les mobilités et les
actions de sobriété nous avons formulé
109 préconisations pour adapter l'école
aux enjeux
climatiques cet objectif je sais que
vous le partagez comme on témoigne le
plan très ambitieux que vous portez
conjointement au ministre Christophe
Béchu ce plan prévoit en effet de
rénover 40000 écoles en 10 ans mais pose
cependant plusieurs questions dont celle
de l'intégration des établissements du
second degré en outre afin de mieux
accompagner les élus notamment ceux des
petites communes nous formulons
plusieurs propositions comme la création
d'un guicher unique en préfecture ou
encore le lancement d'un plan pour
développer les cours végétalisés nous
sommes en effet convaincus que la
végétalisation des cours constitue un
levier essentiel pour faire baisser la
température dans les écoles et pour
sensibiliser les enfants à la protection
de la biodiversité aussi Monsieur le
Ministre pouvez-vous nous préciser
l'ampleur du Plan et du Renov et nous
indiquer de quelle manière nous pourrons
demain mieux accompagner les élus locaux
afin que que nos écoles soient
exemplaires dans l'adaptation aux enjeux
climatiques je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Gabriel ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la
jeunesse merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée gradia Melor l'isolation
thermique de nos écoles de nos collèges
de nos lycées est une absolue
nécessité d'abord pour les conditions de
travail de nos enseignants et les
conditions d'apprentissage de nos
enfants parce que on apprend pas bien
dans une école où il fait trop chaud
l'été et trop froid l'hiver mais c'est
aussi absolument essentiel pour
atteindre nos objectifs de la Stratégie
nationale bas carbone évidemment que
l'isolation thermique des bâtiments
publics et les établissements scolaires
sont le plus grand nombre
d'établissements publics et de bâtiments
publics est absolument nécessaire pour
atteindre nos objectifs en matière de
stratégie nationale bas carbone madame
la députée ce que nous avons mis en
place après l'engagement du président de
la République c'est le plus grand plan
de rénovation scolaire de l'histoire de
notre pays 500 millions d'euros par an à
compter de 2024 qui vont nous permettre
de rénover 40000 écoles sur 10 ans très
concrètement ces dernières années ont
rénové en moyenne un millier d'écoles
par an en 2024 on rénovera 2 milliers
d'écoles et ensuite nous serons à 4000
écoles rénovées par an grâce à
l'engagement de SEP majorités et au
crédit qui sont débloqués 500 millions
d'euros par an pour nous permettre ces
rénovations je veux vous remercier
madame la députée pour le rapport que
vous nous avez remis sur lequel vous
avez travaillé parce qu'il nous permet
de pasfaire l'organisation que nous
avons présenté avec Christophe Béchu
pour que ces fonds puissent être bien
utilisé vous avez raison il faut
prioriser là on en a le plus besoin et
pour ça on a besoin de diagnostic et on
a besoin d'orienter vers ceux qui en ont
le plus besoin vous posez plusieurs
questions dans votre question le guichet
unique oui il faut un guichet unique
dans les préfectures c'est ce que que
nous sommes en train de mettre en place
sur les îlos de fraîcheur dans les
établissements scolaires nous y sommes
favorables et évidemment nous
accompagnerons les collectivités locales
qui s'engageront dans cette voie oui
madame la députée 40000 écoles rénovées
dans les 10 ans qui viennent c'est du
jamais vu dans l'histoire de notre pays
nous pouvons être fi de cet engagement
et des moyens que nous mettons en œuvre
je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Hervé
Solignac pour le groupe socialiste
madame la Première ministre vous nous
avez fait la leçon la semaine dernière
pour une motion de rejet adopté avec des
voix de l'extrême
droite et bien vous voilà en position de
faire adopter une loi non seulement avec
les voix de l'extrême droite mais avec
ses
applaudissements ce ne sont pas des
concessions qui sont faites en ce moment
à la droite la plus dure ce sont des
compromissions un jeu minable de
transaction sur fond de renoncement qui
enterre définitivement le macronisme
originel l'objet même de ce texte vous a
échappé la question migratoire n'est
plus un sujet le seul sujet pour vous
c'est de trouver une majorité et peu
importe le prix à payer puisque la
préférence nationale irrigue déjà le
texte qui est en train de se
préparer la CMP qui se déroule en ce
moment même ne relève plus de la
fabrique de la loi c'est le Congrès des
petits arrangements la fin qui justifie
les
moyens vous redoutez qu'un échec sur ce
texte signe la fin de votre quinquena et
bien je vous le dis une adoption sera de
toute façon une victoire à la pyus vos
soupirs de soullagement seront vite
étouffés par les cris de victoire d'une
extrême droite triomphante cette
séquence prend des allures de naufrage
Politi et parlementair alors chers
collègues de la majorité m'adresse à
vous avec respect et solenité je vous
dis qu'il est encore temps de faire
obstacle à ce texte chacun d'entre vous
a rendez-vous dans quelques heures avec
sa conscience et je vous dis
tranquillement que votre responsabilité
n'a jamais été aussi grande que piétiner
sa conscience ça finit par faire mal que
l'histoire retient toujours le nom des
braves jamais celui de ceux qui ont
failli Gauliste humaniste
progressiste ne renoncez pas soyez à la
hauteur de l'histoire qui s'inscrit dans
ces heures repoussez ce
texte je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
géralde
darmana ministre de l'Intérieur et des
outres
[Applaudissements]
m merci madame la Présidente Mames et
mieurs les
députés monsieur le député venant d'un
parti dont la majorité le président a
proposé la déchéance de nationalité en
réformant la
Constitution votre question ne manque
pas de
selle la vérité monsieur le député c'est
que vous essayez de vous rattraper du
PACT que vous avez mené avec le
rassemblement
national la vérité monsieur le député
c'est que vous n'osez pas dire que vous
n'avez pas voulu discuter du texte
pendant 15 jours la vérité monsieur le
député c'est vous n'osez pas dire que à
l'Assemblée nationale en commission vous
avez été battu très largement et que
vous avez eu peur du débat à l'Assemblée
nationale la vérité monsieur le député
c'est que vous trouvez aujourd'hui des
faux des faux fillants pour expliquer
l'inexplicable vous vous êtes levé d'un
seul homme avec le parti de Madame Le
Pen pour pouvoir applaudir pour quelques
instants monsieur le
député pour la première fois pour la
première fois puisque la CMP vient
d'être conclusive la loi de la
République va permettre d'avoir des
régularisations même François mit 1981
n'avait pas mis dans la loi les
régularisations des métiers en tension
de quel sans papier pour la première
fois dans l'histoire de la République
nous allons interdire à des mineurs
d'être dans des centres de rétention
administratif nous allons offrir à tous
les étrangers des cours de français
ement et obliger l'employeur à pouvoir
prendre ses cours pendant les heures de
travail offrir des titres de séjour aux
gens qui dénoncent ses marchands de
sommeil et sanctionner ce que vous
n'avez jamais fait les employeurs qui
organisent des filières d'immigration
illégale la vérité monsieur le député
c'est que nous allons passer de délit en
crime tous ces passeurs qui vivent du
trafic d'êtres humains parce que vous
n'êtes jamais là pour être ceux qui
accompagnent les policiers les gendarmes
les magistratsieur ministre
contre je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Charles Larsonneur pour le groupe
horizon merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Sébastien
Lecornu ministre des Armées mes chers
collègues l'assemblée se déchire et nous
dansons sur un volcan les points chauds
se multiplie autour du continent
européen situation difficile en Ukraine
guerre à Gaza attaque contre des navires
français et alliés civil comme militaire
en mer Rouge c'est sur ce dernier point
monsieur le ministre que je souhaiterais
revenir aujourd'hui le canal de suè
c'est la colonne vertébrale des échanges
entre l'Europe et l'Asie depuis le mois
d'octobre les agressions se multiplient
nos marins sont en danger les grands
armateurs sensibles à la sécurité de
leurs équipages et à l'impact sur leurs
opérations en matière d'assurance
notamment ont annoncé qu'il suspendaiit
jusqu'à nouvel ordre le franchissement
du canal de Sue à eux seul CMA CGM
apagly mers M Evergreen représente près
de 60 % du trafic mondial de conteneurs
le contournement par le cap représente
15 jours de navigation supplémentaire
ces délais et ses surcûts ajoutés à la
hausse du baril font peser de réelles
inquiétudes pour l'économie européenne
et sur la vie quotidienne de nos
concitoyens déjà durement éprouvé par la
vie cher le 9 décembre la fréade langdoc
aosté à des attaques de drone en
provenance DESCO du Yémen hier en Israël
le secrétaire d'État américain la
défense Lyd Austin a annoncé la création
d'une opétion en coalition baptisé
gardien de la prospérité afin de
contribuer à assurer la liberté de
navigation pardon dans la zone comment
la France entend-elle réagir et
contribuer au rétablissement de la
sécurité au trafic maritime dans la zone
quelle articulation proposez-vous avec
les opérations internationales
européennes déjà en cours en particulier
à génor et à talante je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur Sébastien le Cornu ministre
des Armées oui madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les Députés monsieur
le député larsenur j'aimerais déjà au
nom du gouvernement j'en suis certain au
nom de la représentation nationale
rendre hommage à nos soldats de la
Marine nationale de l'armée de l'air et
de l'armée de terre qui rendent
actuellement leur mission dans des
conditions particulièrement difficiles
au Proche et au Moyen-Orient on le sait
les risques d'escalade sont là la
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères était au proche au
Moyen-Orient milice ch en irac présence
d'un contingent français de 700 soldats
à la finule au Liban et bien s l'action
de la Marine nationale en mer pour les
libertés de circulation comme vous
l'avez rappelé dans votre
question et sur l'ensemble de ces bancs
nous devons évidemment nous mobiliser
nous mobiliser puisque la France
Monsieur le Député déjà largement
présente dans cette région la mission
Agénor àante qui est une mission de
lutte contre la piraterie maritime qui
n'est pas tout à fait l'objet des
menaces de sécurité que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui évidemment les projections
depuis l'hexagone de notre groupe
aéronaval la frégate La languedote qui a
dû effectivement en légitime défense
ouvrir le feu il y a de cela maintenant
plusieurs jours pour défendre un tancire
donc oui les grandes compagnies
maritimes sont inquiètes le secrétaire
d'État rvé Barville les a de nombreuses
reprises au téléphone et donc évidemment
nous devons avoir une stratégie pour se
faire l'initiative américaine monsieur
le député elle est intéressante parce
qu'elle permet d'optimiser de partager
les différents renseignements et option
sur l'ensemble de la région elle
rappelle d'ailleurs aussi les
propositions du président de la
République sur les nécessaires
coalitions sur mesures que nous devons
développer contre les différents groupes
terroristes contre les différentes
menaces en tout cas que la menace que la
région pardon peut peut donner d'emmener
des partenaires régionaux Rallen ben
Salman le ministre de la Défense
d'Arabie Saoudite sera ce soir à Paris
nous aurons l'occasion d'en discuter et
nos échang continu avec le partenaire
américain dans le cadre de notre
autonomie et de notre liberté d'action
monsieur le député dans l'emble de la
région je vous remercie merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre monsieur le député
puisquil me reste quelques secondes
monsieur le ministre merci pour nos
militair merci pour les armes de la
France et je vais avoir une pensée pour
Djibouti un partenaire important dans la
région avec lequel nous renégocions un
traité et qui souffre déjà de la
situation dans la zone je vous remercie
merci
beaucoup la parole est à Madame
Géraldine grand pour le rassemblement
[Applaudissements]
nationalés question s'adresse à madame
la Première ministre 15illard00000 €
c'est la somme que dépensent chaque
année les départements français pour
l'accueil des mineurs non accompagnés
dit MNA cette somme vous la connaissez
et elle vous a été rappelée à Strasbourg
lors du congrès réunissant les
départements de France nous le savons
bien les départements assument la
quasi-ttalité de la charge financière de
la mission d'accueil et d'évaluation des
MNA qui vient s'ajouter aux dépenses
sociales en faveur de nos compatriotes
les plus fragiles et surtout à sa
mission première de protection de
l'enfance aussi c'est le cri d'alarme
lancé par les départements que je veux
porter aujourd'hui vous l'avez entendu
comme moi madame la Première ministre
les départements sont dans l'incapacité
d'absorber la hausse continue du nombre
de personnes qui se présentent comme
mineurs non accompagnés et d'en assumer
seul le coût financier mon département
le dou avec d'autres fait lui-même face
à un flux migratoire sans précédent et
sa présidente alerte sur la hausse des
MNA accueilliis pour évaluation cet été
ils étaient environ 700 aujourd'hui ils
sont près d'un millier or les
dispositifs d'accueil sont déjà saturés
par une hausse d'enfants confiés les
départements sont asphyxiés madame la
Première ministre l'argent que les
départements consacrent au mineurs non
accompagnés c'est de l'argent en moins
pour la protection de l'enfance pour les
centres départementaux de l'enfant et de
la famille et j'en veux pour preuve des
dysfonctionnements graves au CDF la
maison de la colline et la maison Victor
Hugo à exincour dans le doux qui souffre
directement un manque de moyens de
personnel professionnel éducateur
appelle à l'aide la surcharge de travail
cumulée à la complexité de l'accueil
d'enfants en grande détresse
psychologique a conduit 6 éducateurs sur
7 à l'épuisement et l'arrêt maladie à
cela s'ajoute l'indici pour ces enfants
la nuit au moment du coucher les crises
les angoisses les cris les hurlements
expriment la détresse de chacun madame
la Première ministre quand l'État
assumera-t-il financièrement la totalité
de l'accueil des personnes qui se
présentent quand merci beaucoup
merci la parole est à Madame Charlotte
cobel ministre en charge de
l'enfance merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les Députés madame la
députée Grangier oui nous partageons
avec vous le constat que la protection
de l'enfance est aujourd'hui en tension
oui nous partageons aujourd'hui le
constat qu'il y a une reprise des flux
migratoires qui vient évidemment
complexifier la situation de la
protection de l'enfance mais non nous ne
partageons pas la même valeur un enfant
quel qu'il soit qu'il soit français ou
qu'il soit étranger en situation
d'isolement sur notre territoire est un
enfant en danger et il doit être protégé
nous ne partageons pas non plus votre
constat madame sur ce que fait le
gouvernement depuis 2016 cette majorité
le gouvernement a fait en sorte de
d'améliorer l'évaluation de la minorité
pour écarter les personnes se prétendant
mineur et qui ne sont pas mineurs le
gouvernement et cette majorité é à
vootter des dispositifs pour faciliter
la prise en charge des mineurs pour
apporter un soutien financier du
gouvernement la première ministre a
entendu il y a quelques semaines le cri
d'alerte des départements et a augmenté
l'enveloppe du gouvernement au soutien
des départements les départements
eux-mêmes interrogés ont manifesté leur
souhait de garder cette compétence ils
nous ont demander de travailler la le
dispositif pour l'améliorer c'est ce que
nous avons fait en mettant en place il y
a une semaine et demi avec le président
sauvadé un groupe de travail pour
améliorer encore le dispositif et
notamment accélérer les recours et
accélérer la mise à l'abri des mineurs
madame la députée ça fait depuis 2016
que le gouvernement est engagé auprès
des départements pour assurer cette ce
respect un mineur qu'il soit français ou
étranger quand il est isolé est en
danger et doit être
protégé je vous remercie madame
la
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Benjamin Lucas pour le
groupe
écologiste merci madame la
Présidente il est des moments où il se
joue ici bien plus que de la politique
bien plus que la loi où se joue
finalement l'identité de la République
et l'âme de notre pays alors que
l'extrême droite vient d'annoncer avoir
engrangé une victoire idéologique
majeure et s'apprête à voter votre texte
sur
l'immigration je ne peux pas je ne veux
pas croire chers collègues de la
majorité présidentielle que vous
puissiez toutes et tous cautionner ce
qui a été fait sous la dicté du
gouvernement en commission mixte
paritaire cautionnement pour les
étudiants internationaux retour de la
préférence nationale fin de
l'automaticité du droit du
restriction regroupement familial
abandon des régularisation par le
travail volonté de réformer l'aide
médicale d'État en 2024 vous avez cédé
surtout et vous avez surtout
cédé le sujet mes chers collègues en cet
instant ce n'est plus la gauche ce n'est
plus la droite ce n'est plus la majorité
ce n'est plus l'opposition c'est le
serment
humaniste conclu avec les Françaises et
les Français en 2017 et en 2022 quand
des millions d'entre eux ont choisi de
faire barrage à l'extrême droite raciste
dans notre pays chers collègues soyons
collectivement dignes de la dignité des
Français je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Gérald ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outremers
[Musique]
monsieur Lucas madame la Présidente
pardon monsieur Lucas ça vous faisait
moins de peine la semaine dernière qu
rassemblé nationale se levait pour vous
applaudir monsieur Lucas en plus d'aller
chercher les voies du Front national
vous mentez parce que dans le texte de
la CMP il y a bien la régularisation des
travailleurs des
attention vous mentez parce qu'il y a
bien la fin des mineurs dans les centres
de
rétention et Monsieur Lucas les deux
sénateurs du rassemblement national ont
voté contre le texte du Sénat voilà
qu'un jour et aujourd'hui Madame Le Pen
vient deéourir au secours de la victoire
mais c'est pour voir votre mine déconfie
en ayant voté la motion de rejet
monsieur
Lucas alors oui
oui nous prenons nos
responsabilités et Monsieur Lucas
n'inaventez pas n'importe quoi grâce à
l'action de la première ministre et de
la majorité il y a des distinction entre
ceux qui travaillent et ceux qui ne
travaillent pas mais cette distinction a
déjà été faite en 1988 par Michel Rocard
pour le
RMI je vous remercie monsieur le
député monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur vous êtes
lamentable nous n'avons pas de leçon à
recevoir de la part de ceux qui font
entrer des parentiers du programme de
Jean-Marie Le Pen dans la loi nous
n'avons pas de leçon à recevoir de ceux
qui offrent une victoire historique à
l'extrême droite rien ne vous oblig à
convoquer une CMP rien ne vous obliger à
présenter ce texte rejeté par
l'Assemblée nationale vous avez cdé
l'histoire vous regarde elle vous jugera
sé merci
beaucoup monsieur le
[Musique]
ministre monsieur Lucas
s'il vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
plaît monsieur Lucas nous nous
connaissons peu mais moi je n'ai pas
quitté la région où le Front national
était fort pour me faire rlire ailleurs
moi j'ai toujours battu le rassemblement
national je n'ai pas la quitté la région
des Haut- de- France pour me présenter
en
île-de-fance j'ai battu le Front
national à toutes les élections et vos
le son de morale républicaine je les
mettrai dans ma poche quand je faisais à
la tribune des clins d'œils et Madame Le
Pen la vérité à Monsieur Lucas c'est que
vous avez renoncé à parler au peuple de
gauche pour les protéger nous leur
parlons et nous les éviterons le
rassemblement
national je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Marc zuulzi pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à madiam agès panier runaché
ministre en charge de la transition
énergétique l'urgence climatique est au
cœur de notre action nous luttons contre
cette urgence climatique par des actions
pragmatiques en particulier en matière
de transport nous avons voté le texte
sur les services express régionaux
métropolitains grâce à l'action menée
par Clément bonne et Christophe Béchu
nous agissons pour des bonus écologiques
pour des primes à la conversion qui
permet ett d'avoir une politique
ambitieuse et la semaine dernière nous
avons porté ensemble une mesure
importante en matière d'écologie c'est
le leasing social la voiture à moins de
100 € ce dispositif permettra à nos
concitoyens les plus modestes d'accéder
à un véhicule électrique à moins de 100
€ ces véhicules circuleront dès l'année
prochaine dès l'année prochaine et et
concerneront des véhicules français et
européens c'est un pas de plus vers la
fin de l'utilisation des énergie fossile
nous portons ainsi des solutions
concrètes à tous nos concitoyens une
écologie populaire une écologie des
territoires c'est aussi un sujet de
souveraineté industrielle puisque c'est
une chance pour notre industrie car nous
donnons la priorité à notre industrie
française pour carboner nos transports
nos mobilités du quotidien mais il faut
aller plus loin toujours plus loin pour
donner le meilleur à nos concitoyens
nous devons massifier ce dispositif
alors ma question est simple madame la
ministre quels sont les perspective pour
massifier le dispositif et faire que les
transports décbonés soient accessibles à
tous nos concitoyens merci je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame
AG ministre de la transition
énergétique merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le Président zouis avec la avec
le président de la République et la
première ministre nous nous sommes
engagés à accompagner les Français avec
des solutions concrètes pour la
transition énergétique parce que la
transition énergétique que nous portons
c'est une transition juste c'est une
transition qui répond au besoins de
chacun des Français là où ils sont c'est
ce que nous faisons avec le leasing
social le leasing c'est cette solution
qui permet d'avoir un véhicule à 100 €
par mois un véhicule électrique de 50 à
150 € selon les modèles choisis et qui
est une promesse de campagne du
président de la République une promesse
de campagne que nous mettons en œuvre
une promesse de campagne qui est bonne
pour le climat bonne pour le
portefeuille et le pouvoir d'achat des
Français est bonne pour notre emploi et
notre industrie bonne pour le climat
parce que le véhicule élect
c'est de à 5 fois moins d'émissions de
carbone qu'un véhicule thermique bonne
pour le portefeuille car rouler en
électrique c'est trois fois moins cher
en carburant qu'une voiture thermique et
enfin bonne pour l'industrie et l'emploi
car seuls les modèles qui ont une
véritable empreinte environnementale
vertueuse seront retenu pour ce
dispositif des modèles qui sont
fabriqués en France et qui sont fabriqué
en Europe alors qui pourra en bénéficier
ben de conditions 50 % des Français
pourront y avoir accès à condition
qu'ils remplissent une deuxième
condition qui est soit de faire 15 km le
matin et le soir pour aller à leur
travail soit de faire 8000 km pour
travailler lorsqu'ils sont par exemple
aide à domicile ou aide soignante pour
eux le 1er janvier la plateforme ouvrira
et vous pouvez compter sur moi pour
faire en sorte que les 25000 premiers
véhicules électriques qui sont mis à
disposition soit augmenté main dans la
main avec les constructeurs c'est une
mesure pour les français pour les
classes populaires qui travaillent pour
les classes moyennes merci à vous merci
beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à monsieur Éric
cocrel pour le groupe la France
insoumise merci cette question est à
madame la ministre des Affaires
étrangères madame Colona je veux d'abord
rendre hommage à Ahed Abou Chamla qui
travaillait depuis plus de 20 ans pour
la diplomatie française mort sous les
bombardements et dont je regrette qu'on
ait refusé de le consacrer ici une
minute de
silence je veux penser aux otages tué
cette semaine à notre compatriote Ia
toédano mais aussi à la mort des trois
autres otages tués par zal et qui ont en
réalité connu le sort des 16608 civils
palestiniens dont 70 % de femmes et
d'enfants tués depuis le 7 octobre qui
peut douter maintenant des véritables
objectifs de guerre du gouvernement
netanahou qui après le Nord bombarde le
sud de Gaza là où il avait demandé
justement au Palestiniens de se réfugier
qui peut toutter qu'il s'agit moins
d'éradiquer le Hamas que d'en finir avec
Gaza et la sjordanie comme territoire
palestinien madame la ministre vous avez
été la première de l'exécutif à avoir
appelé un cesser le feu que nous portons
depuis le départ vous allez même
désormais plus loin après la mort de
l'agent de diplomatie vous avez dit je
cite que la France condamne ce
bombardement d' d'habitation qui a causé
la mort de nombreus autres civils je
regrette qu'il est fallu ce drame pour
condamner clairement ce type de
bombardement mais je veux croire Madame
le Ministre que cela vaut désormais pour
tous les bombardements israéliens qui
ciblent expressément les Palestiniens
depuis la colonisation accrue en
sixjordanie vous avez dit je cite en
sjordanie la construction de colonie
s'accélère en violation flagrante du
droit internationale de plus les colons
commettent des exactions vers des
Palestiniens les privant de leur droit
et de leur terr nous ne pvons pas
l'accepter des mesures seront prises
vous parlez de mesures à prendre et vous
avez raison Madame la Ministre comment
passer de la parole aux actes peut-on se
contenter d'un appel au cesser le feu
quand l'ONU parle de nettoyage ethnique
et de risque génocidaire n'est-il pas
temps de reconnaître un État palestinien
et de porter le déploiement d'une force
d'interposition de l'ONU n'est-il pas
temps de prendre des sanctions
économiques à l'encontre d'Israël afin
de faire cesser ce carnage de retirer
ces troupes de Gaza pré
envoule merci beaucoup la parole est à
Madame Catherine Colona ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député coocrel monsieur le
Président cocrel devrais-je dire
président j'étais au ProcheOrient
dimanche et lundi en Israël et à ramala
auprès de l'Autorité palestinienne
dimanche à Beyrouth hier et oui monsieur
le député il est possible d'être au sol
à la fois des Israéliens et des
Palestiniens en Israël en plus des
entretiens politiques je me suis rendu
au Centre d'Identification des victimes
des attentats terroristes du 7 octobre
la réalité monsieur le débuté est
glaçante c'est celle d'une barbarie sans
nom qui a visé beaucoup de femmes sinon
principalement des femmes mutilé profané
défiguré presque toutes alors rien ne
justifie jamais cela rien ne justifie
jamais le terrorisme n'oublions pas le 7
octobre mais j'ai dit
aussi mais j'ai dit aussi que trop de
civils meurent à Gaza et que cela ne
peut pas continuer ainsi sans créer trop
de souffrance et sans créer trop de
ressentiments et ce message s'adresse
aussi à Israël bien évidemment en sé
jour d' plus tard j'ai rencontré des
fermiers Palestiniens victimes des
exactions et menace des colons
extrémistes israéliens ces colons qui
provoquent des violences et mèent des
exaction inacceptable alors je l'ai dit
je le répète la France ne restera pas
silencieuse mais de plus elle prendra
des mesures à titre national ce travail
est en cours et nous demandons à Israël
non seulement de faire toute la lumière
sur ces actes mais de prendre des mesure
car le climat d'impunité qui règne
encourage ces exactions ces terres sont
palestiniennes elles feront partie d'un
État palestinien car nous le savons tous
seule la solution à deux état peut
amener la paix et la sécurité pour tous
c'est notre objectif et je suis sûr
monsieur le député que c'est le vôtre
aussi merci je vous merci Madame la
Ministre la parole est à monsieur Éric
poet pour le groupe les
républicains merci madame la Présidente
madame la ministre des solidarités et
des familles en décembre 2017 le
président de la République promettait de
ne plus voir personne dans la rue et
d'apporter d'ici la fin de son premier
quinquena un toit à toutes celles et
ceux qui sont sans abri malheureusement
6 ans après pauvreté et grande précarité
s'aggrave selon un récent rapport du
Secours Catholique le nombre de
personnes vivant sous le seuil de
pauvreté atteint un triste record avec
plus de 9 millions de Français concernés
la plupart dis qu'en moyenne de 538 €
mensuel et 95 % vivent en de ça enfin le
nombre de personnes étrangères dont un
tiers sont en situation irrégulière est
en forte augmentation plus
qu'inquiétante la situation est devenue
dramatique l'inflation alimentaire et
énergétiques les inégalités de santé le
dérèglement climatique fragilise les
plus précaires jusqu'aux travailleurs
pauvres l'action des bénévoles et des
associations caritatives sont
elles-mêmes touchées elles sont à bout
de souffle dans ma ville jean- Lespin
Croix Rouge resto du cœur Secours
populaire coup de pouce et leur
bénévoles sonneent l'alarme leurs charg
ont augmenté de 15 % et elles ne peuvent
plus assurer l'aide alimentaire ni même
répondre au 25 % de demandes
supplémentaires l'heure n'est plus à
l'incantation et le sujet ne peut plus
s'accommoder du en même temps de
nouvelles solidarités doivent être mises
en œuvre je pense notamment à une
réduction d'impôts de 100 % applicable
au versement des dons à destination des
associations caritatives à la veille des
fêtes de fin d'année le chantier est
urgent et même décisif madame la
ministre alors allez-vous contre le fléo
de la grande précarité agir de façon
forte et déterminée allez-vous faire
votre ma proposition car se chauffer ou
se nourrir ne peut plus être la seule
alternative proposée au
français je vous remercie la parole est
à Madame Aurore berger ministre des
solidarité des familles merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Eric poet
vous avez évidemment raison sur la
situation qui est extrêmement difficile
trop difficile pour de très nombreux
Français c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous agissons il y a pas de
procrastination en la matière il y a la
nécessité d'agir d'agir d'abord en
direct au bénéfice des personnes qui
sont concerné par la pauvreté par le
risque de l'isolement social et de
l'exclusion c'est ce qu'on fait avec à
la fois le plan lutte contre la pauvreté
dans le précédent quinquena en lien
direct avec les collectivités locales
avec les départements avec les
métropoles avec les CCS les C
parce que c'est aussi une démarche de
partenariat pour juguler évidemment la
pauvreté ce que nous avons renforcé avec
le PCT des solidarités nous avons
présenté avec la première ministre c'est
20 milliards d'euros mobilisés sur ce
quinquena parce que la lutte contre la
pauvreté c'est d'abord la question de
l'insertion professionnelle parce que la
dignité elle se retrouve dans l'emploi
et dans l'insertion professionnelle
évidemment c'est la question des lutte
contre les difficultés objectives à
retrouver un emploi je pense à la
question des modes de garde évidemment
pour les enf enfant et c'est un soutien
très renforcé pour nos enfants un tiers
des crédits sur la lutte contre la
pauvreté sont en direction de nos
enfants qui sont évidemment les plus
fragiles et les plus vulnérables et puis
évidemment les associations dont vous
parlez dans le cadre du PLF nous avons
été assez loin puisque non seulement
nous avons consolidé augmenté
considérablement les moyens sur l'aide
alimentaire c'était 156 millions l'an
dernier ce sera 185 millions l'an
prochain nous avons aussi maintenu vous
le savez la déduction fiscale le
dispositif di Coluche qui permet d'avoir
75 % de déduction fiscale jusqu'à 1000 €
c'est un dispositif essentiel plébiscité
qui permet d'avoir plus de donateurs je
le dis aussi parce que les associations
vous le savez c'est maintenant qu'elles
ont besoin de nous qu'elles ont besoin
de l'État des collectivités des citoyens
l'essentiel de la collecte des
associations et des dons c'est le mois
de décembre alors il y a ce que l'État
fait il y a ce que les entreprises
doivent faire et ce que les
collectivités font il y a aussi ce que
nous faisons en tant que citoyens et je
sais qu'évidemment les Français sauront
y répondre avec
générosité je vous remercie madame la
ministre monsieur le député oui merci
madame la ministre de vos réponses je
pense qu'il faut que l'on travaille le
couple maire association au plus proche
du terrain ça doit être une priorité de
travailler avec les maires et les
associations dans les quartiers dans les
communes dans nos villages et dans nos
communes merci
merci la parole est à monsieur Guillaume
pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à monsieur Clément Baon
ministre chargé des transports dans 6
mois notre pays et en particulier de
l'agglomération parisienne accueilleront
les Jeux Olympiques et paralympiqu et à
ce titre seront au centre de l'atention
du monde entier je suis convaincu que
chacun d'entre nous a à cœur la réussite
de ces jeux non pas que nous ayons tous
été supporteurs de ce projet mais parce
qu'à ce moment de sa réalisation il n'y
a pas d'autres option que de le réussir
nous avons voté deux lois à cet effet
une en 2018 et une en mai 2023 dont j'ai
eu l'honneur d'être rapporteur je veux
saluer à cet égard le travail de votre
collègue la ministre ouea Castera cette
loi était consacrée à la sécurité des
jeux je me réjoui en saluant avec
respect ces détracteurs que le décret
qui en était la cheville ouvrière et qui
était consacré à l'analyse des données
de vidéo protection a été publié sans
polémique pour garantir la sécurité de
ces jeux vous avez monsieur le ministre
ministre une responsabilité immense
celle d'assurer de bon fonctionnement
des transports la Coupe du monde de
rugby a été sur ce plan comme sur les
autres une réussite et nous pouvons en
être fiier les j seront toutefois d'une
échelle autrement plus importante ce
sont en effet des millions de visiteurs
touristes athlètes médias qui vont
devoir se déplacer dans la région et
dans tout le pays sur des territoires
qui devront tout de même continuer à
fonctionner or il se dit que nous ne
serions pas prêts la mère de Paris a
affirmé qu'il n'y aura pas nombre de
trains et la fréquence nécessaire durant
l'été 2024 en précisant qu'il y aurait
des difficultés avec la station duur e
de la Porte Maillot et je vous avoue
monsieur le ministre que nombre de
salariés d'acteurs économique de ma
circonscription du valdoise se demande
comment tout cela va se passer alors que
15 millions de visiteurs sont attendus
dans une région qui ne peut pas et ne
doit pas s'arrêter de vivre pouvez-vous
monsieur le ministre nous détailler les
mesures qui seront prises et mises en
œuvre pour éviter un confinement
d'Olympique en un un mot pour réussir ce
challenge et permettre à tous de se
déplacer au mieux pendant les jeux je
vous remercie je vous remercie mon cher
collègu la parole est à monsieur Clément
bonne ministre en charge des
transports merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député vult vous relayez un
certain nombre d'interrogations
parfaitement légitimes de nos
concitoyens notamment francilien y
compris dans votre circonscription et
vous ne relayez pas mais vous soulevez
un certain nombre de choses qui ont fait
l'objet de polémique voire de FA news
ces dernières semaines c'est l'occasion
de les démentir je réunirai à nouveau
pour la 9e fois avec Amélie ou Castera
avec Fadila catabi un comité des
mobilités pour faire le point sur
l'avancement de chacun des chantiers
l'accessibilité les infrastructures le
service qui sera offert au francilien
comme au monde entier que nous
accueillons et je veux le redire c'est
un honneur une fierté pour Paris pour
l'île-de-fance et pour la France
d'accueillir après 100 ans les Jeux
olympiques d'été et nous ferons tout
pour réussir ce défi qui sera d'abord un
défi de transport vous l'avez dit la
plus grande opération de trans transport
que notre pays a connu 800000 personnes
par jour en plus dans le transport
public 13 millions de visiteurs et nous
avons pris un engagement qui est inédit
qu'aucune ville avait pris avant Paris
et avant la France c'est d'avoir 100 %
des sites pour 100 % des spectateurs qui
soient desservis en transport public et
nous le réussirons nous sommes en train
d'augmenter l'offre de transport de 15 %
pour que pendant les j tout le monde
puisse y avoir accès et ce défi
écologique et ce défi français sera là
aussi une grande fierté je veux le dire
il est évidemment hors de question
évidemment de questions d'avoir je ne
sais quel le confinement olympique
d'empêcher de circuler les Parisiens les
Franciliens les Français qui sont là qui
veulent travailler qui veulent
simplement mener leur vie comme ils
l'entendent bien sûr il y aura des
mesures de sécurité des mesures
d'organisation nous les mettons en œuvre
avec la Ville de Paris avec la région
conjointement pour limiter le plus
possible les impacts sur la vie
quotidienne des Parisiens et des
Franciliens c'est ceuxa qui devrait nous
réunir plutôt que des petites polémique
stérile enfin j'y insiste les Jeux
Olympiques et pour les transports en
particulier sont un formidable
accélérateur de l'Invest ement dans le
transport public sans les Jeux
Olympiques nous n'aurions pas 67 gares
qui seront mises en accessibilité d'ici
l'été 2024 sans les Jeux Olympiques nous
ne serions pas au rendez-vous pour
prolonger la ligne 14 pour des millions
de franc cylien pour le RER etol pour
1000 taxis qui seront accessibles aux
personnes à mobilité réduite c'est un
formidable accélérateur et un formidable
héritage pour notre ville notre capitale
notre région et notre pays je vous
remercie monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Laurent Alexandre pour le groupe la
France insoumis
monsieur le ministre de la Santé les
professionnels soignants ne cessent
d'alerter sur la dégradation de leurs
conditions d'exercice et sur les
inégalités de santé en France inégalité
sociale avec 13 ans d'écart d'espérance
de vie entre les plus riches et les plus
pauvres inégalité territoriale avec 2
ans d'espérance de vie en moins pour les
habitants des zones rurales la
désertification médicale est une réalité
15 % des avéronnés n'ont pas de médecin
traitant dans l'hôpital public on est
proche de l'effondrement les urgences
doivent garantir une égalité de
traitement pour les populations or dans
certains hôpitaux comme à de caseville
les urgences sont régulées depuis
l'application de la loiriste
concrètement tout patient tout
professionnel de santé est obligé de
joindre le 15 avant de se déplacer ou
d'orienter un patient aux urgences
certains sont renvoyés vers un autre
hôpital situé à plus de 45 minutes cela
génère des angoisses et en danger les
patients le système devait être
provisoire mais il s'installe et les
urgences pourraient être complètement
fermées certain jour le personnel est
écuré de ne pouvoir faire son travail
correctement en raison du retrait de
l'État ils sont épuisé jusqu'à quand
tiendront-ils entre 3000 et 5000
médecins titulaires d'un diplôme de
médecine en runion européenne exerçant
dans notre pays depuis des années serait
contraint de raccrocher en début d'année
prochaine chaîne en raison d'un manque
de poste ouvert par votre gouvernement
vous stigmatisez les travailleurs
étrangers qui participent à faire tenir
notre pays debout et vous videz nos
hôpitaux de leurs médecins alors que la
situation est proche du chaos écoutez
nos propositions de bon sens
saisissez-vous de la proposition de loi
transpartisane visant à r à réguler
l'installation des médecins pour lutter
contre les déserts médicaux étendez aux
établissements privés le plafond de
rémunération des médecins intérimaires
du public ma question très simple
allez-vous enfin agir pour garantir
l'égalité d'accès à la santé et sauver
l'hôpital
public je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Aurélien Rousseau ministre de la santé
et de la
prévention madame madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député en effet le centre
hospitalier en effet le centre
hospitalier pierre delpèche à de
caseville connait des de graves de
lourdes difficultés pour maintenir le
service d'urgence mais pas simplement
depuis la loiriste parce que cette loi
portée par la rapporteur générale elle
était indispensable elle était utile
parce qu'on avait des mercenaires des
mercenire qui
portait qui
[Musique]
qui
alors des serv des
services des services d'urgence Un
service
d'urgence monsieur le ministre allez-y
laissez-le parler s'il vous
[Musique]
plaît ça l'hôpital l'hôpital de
l'hôpital de decaseville fait partie de
ceux pour lesquels monsieur le député
pour répondre directement à votre
question nous nous battons et nous nous
battons au quotidien avec les personnels
médicaux et notamment avec le chef du
service des urgences auquel je veux
rendre hommage le docteur
bcker aujourd'hui de caseville ça n'est
pas un hôpital qui est en train de
mourir c'est un hôpital sur lequel nous
réinstallons le service de mammographie
nous allons annoncer des investissements
pour le reconstruire après l'incendie
qui a eu lieu il y a quelques années il
y a des consultations avancées pardon à
partir de l'hôpital de Rodez et nous
nous battons pour remettre en place un
service de chirurgie ambulatoire mais
oui notre combat quotidien le combat
quotidien de l'ARS mais aussi des
professionnels de santé c'est de
permettre la tenue de ces lignes
d'urgence et là Monsieur le Député je
dois vous rappeler une règle simple
aujourd'hui toute urgence vitale qui se
présente devant le centre hospitalier de
de caseville est accueilli toute urgence
vitale est accueillie par contre en
effet nous sommes et nous avons mis en
place une régulation par le Centre 15
pour dégager
beauoup monsieur le ministre
partie rendez-vous merci Monsieur le
Ministre votre temps est
écoulé la parole est à Madame la
vice-présidente la por pour le
rassemblement national merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Agriculture et
de la souveraineté alimentaire monsieur
le ministre le 14 décembre dernier le
Conseil européen a décidé d'ouvrir les
négociations en ve de l'adhésion
d'Ukraine et de la Moldavie à l'Union
européenne une perspective qui inquiète
légitimement emble de nos agriculteurs
surtout vu votre engagement transparent
jusqu'à présent en cas d'adhésion
l'Ukraine va devenir la première
puissance agricole de l'Union européenne
et de très loin la première bénéficiaire
de la politique agricole commune avec
une prévision de 186 milliards sur 7 ans
soit le trip de ce que perçoit la France
entre 2021 et 2027 l'Ukraine ne joue pas
avec les mêmes règles que nous le modèle
agricole est industriel et productiviste
il repose sur d'immenses expplloitation
et presque entièrement tourné vers
l'exportation il y a de jours vous avez
été interrogé sur le sujet vous vous
avez misis le souhait que le géant
agricole ukrainien une fois intégré à
l'UE va chercher à conquérir des marchés
dans le monde sans entrer en concurrence
avec nos producteurs mais sincèrement
qui peut croire qui peut croire un seul
instant que nous allons être en mesure
d'éviter une telle concurrence alors que
l'Union européenne est déjà le premier
marché d'export des premiers des
produits alimentaires Ukrainiens qui
portaient par des coups de reviens
dérisoires ne font que progresser
monsieur le ministre lorsque vous êtes
interpellé sur l'injustice subie par nos
producteurs et la concurrence déloyales
votre réponse est malheureusement
souvent la même l'interdiction des
semences de betterab enrobé quand nos
voisins peuvent utiliser l'acétamie
prise et donc que nous avons ces
produits sur le sol français vous n'y
pouvez rien vous me répondez c'est
l'Europe la réglementation qui permet
l'opacité sur l'origine des mélanges de
miel malgré la crise de la filière
apicole française et vous êtes
interpellé par de nombreux courriers à
ce sujet là encore vous nous répondez
vous n'y pouvez rien c'est l'Europe à
titre de mon au titre de mon département
je vous interrogais sur la dégradation
du nutriscore du pruneo d'agin là encore
vous n'y pouvez rien c'est l'Europe et
des exemples de ce style il y a
malheureusement dans toutes les filière
mais Monsieur le Ministre votre rôle ce
n'est pas d'acquesser les demandes de la
Commission européenne nos agriculteurs
il demandent ils attendent autre chose
alors que vous avez renoncé à défendre
des aelleurs Français contre la
suspension des droits de douane sur les
produits Ukrainiens allez-vous enfin
placer notre agriculture française en
tête de votre engagement
bra je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Marc fenau ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée j'ai l'impression que vous
connaissez mal l'Europe
et que vous connais mais écoutez la
réponse je sais que ça vous gêne et que
vous connaissez pas à quel point le fait
que l'Europe n''est pas pris de décision
nous met en difficulté sur le miel c'est
parce que nous n'avons pas un étiquetage
européen que nous avons une difficulté
c'est ça la réalité sur le nutrcore le
nutrcore c'est un un dispositif que nous
avons créé à 6 sans l'Europe donc ne
venez pas imputer à l'Europe ce qu'elle
n'est pas parce que je sais que ça
arrange vos combats et votre idéologie
mais on peut pas dire n'importe quoi sur
l'Europe deuxième élément j'ai la
réponse vous aurez peut-être le micro
après j'ai la j'essaie de vous répondre
deème élément j'aurais aimé que vous
ayez un mot sur l'Ukraine sur la
solidarité qu'on drit à l'Ukraine la
désorganisation des marchés mondiaux
c'est pas l'Ukraine c'est la Russie
c'est vos amis russes qui l'ont provoqué
la guerre c'est les Russes c'est pas les
Ukrainiens l'inflation des prix c'est
les Russes c'est pas les Ukrainiens qui
a cherché à faire la guerre ça ne sont
pas les Ukrainiens alors donc nous
devons être à la fois solidaire des
Ukrainiens ça nempêche pas d'être lucide
madame la députée et donc on est lucide
dans la négociation si vous connaissiez
l'Europe vous saiez qu'un processus
d'adhésion c'est un processus long et si
vous connaissiez l'Europe vous sariez
que pour adhérer à l'Europe il faut
prendre ce qu'on appelle l'acqui
communautaire et l'acqui communautaire
c'est quoi c'est d'avoir les mêmes
règles dernier élément c'est la France
par ma voix qui a fait en sorte que dans
le débat de de l'ouverture de
l'ouverture sur les marchés on fasse en
sorte que la période soit courte et
qu'on ait une clause de revoyure au mois
de juin oui c'est par ma vois parce que
c'est le ministre de l'Agriculture qui
s'exprime
et donc on a fait en sorte que nous aons
des mesures on a fait en sorte que des
mesures soi prise pour veiller à ce que
les marchés soi pas déstabilisés mais je
le répète la déstabilisation des marchés
elle est imputable à vos amis Russ et ça
vous emportez la
responsabilité je vous remercie monsieur
le ministre la séance des questions
gouvernement est terminé la sé
suspend